knock at the cabin invites moviegoers to
once again step into the twisty world of
M Night Shyamalan as usual there's more
going on between the credits than you
might expect
after the opening credits the film cuts
to a young girl named Wynn sitting in an
open field attempting to put
grasshoppers in a jar afterwards she
uses colored pencils to write cute notes
and statistics about the various
grasshoppers which he even assigns names
not long after the film introduces Dave
Batista's Burly but sensitive character
Leonard who approaches win despite some
initial hesitation in speaking with a
stranger she has a conversation with
Leonard where he reveals he too enjoys
capturing grasshoppers he urges her to
be gentle so as not to spook them
foreshadowing what's to come essentially
all four of the strangers with prophetic
Visions would trap the family in their
cabin and try their best to keep the
hostages calm as they consider
sacrificing one of their own obviously
this doesn't go well these efforts are
gentle enclosure include attending to
their medical needs keeping winds safe
and giving their backstories to help
humanize themselves the cabin itself is
an allegory for the grasshopper jar as
they enter there is no chance for escape
when Leonard first appears talking to
win the camera begins acting
unsettlingly off balance tilting further
as a conversation progresses known as a
Dutch angle the effect is employed to
help create a jarring Eerie off-center
feel director M Night Shyamalan uses the
technique repeatedly to portray
Leonard's torn psychological State the
man has a task he doesn't want to do
which involves him killing torturing and
carrying the burden of the fate of the
entire world on his mind everything in
his world view is thus off-center and
not quite right he failed to choose
the world
the use of the Dutch angle is also in
keeping with shyamalan's 90s Thriller
theme classic 90s films are crafted and
off-kill to feel with Dutch angles
include 12 Monkeys Mission Impossible
and the City of lost children
after the four strangers with visions
invade the cabin and tie up Andrew and
Eric while keeping an eye on wind the
flat screen TV shows a colorful animated
cartoon presumably something Wim was
watching before going to catch
grasshoppers earlier that day afterwards
Leonard attempts to keep things as light
and stress-free as possible saying the
show looks fun and educational he then
adds us like a lot of Children's
Entertainment the show seems determined
to instill in kids a sense of empathy
and understanding afterwards London
leaves the other strangers to open up
about their past their jobs their hopes
and dreams my son is gonna die his name
is Charlie the point of this as Eric
later says is to give the family empathy
for Humanity as a whole since the people
sent to the cabin all represented
important aspects of it essentially the
family in the film has to make the
ultimate sacrifice to save the world but
that sacrifice can't be made in a vacuum
they have to be reminded that if they
damn the world they'll be essentially
dumbing people just like themselves with
families dreams and love in their hearts
it's easy for people to be less
empathetic when they are shielded or
distant from the suffering of others but
learning to empathize with Humanity
whether through a children's show or
through learning about people's lives is
imperative
news reports are frequently used as
Exposition in many types of films and
Shyamalan has certainly used his share
he even appears in a cameo with knock of
the cabin in an infomercial that airs
prior to one's such breaking news report
it's a great way to Dole out a lot of
exposition in a short amount of time
which is great for genre films eager to
get backstory out of the way as quickly
as possible and get to the more
interesting aspects such as the twisty
narrative Shyamalan has a unique place
in this particular cinematic Corner
however having created one of the best
fake news reports in film history in
2002 science the main family of
characters are stuck in their
Pennsylvania home watching a news report
of camcorder footage at a Brazilian
birthday drawing a normal kid's birthday
party the blurry footage suddenly
reveals what looks to be a green-skinned
humanoid alien the news report scenes a
knock at the cabin particularly the
plague of 50-foot tidal waves is filmed
in a similar way as signs in both films
a cameraman is filming people having fun
but for fun finding themselves
confronted with something beyond their
comprehension
other strangers who invaded the cabin
truly getting horrific visions of the
end times or are they lying to Gaslight
the family into harming each other as
punishment for being a gay couple
raising an immigrant child are these
strangers living a shared delusion based
on a deranged Echo chamber of Internet
misinformation or could they be correct
one early clue that the film uses to
substantiate the validity of their
visions and prophecies as well as the
Divine will of avenge for God is when
they kill their first acolyte Rupert
Grints Redmond after the family refuses
to sacrifice one of their own Redmond
gets on his knees and puts a mask over
his head the other strangers getting
their makeshift weapons ready to
ritualistically kill him while this is
happening the viewer can see how robotic
and cold they get while performing this
sacrificial ritual with each speaking
some ancient prayer in unison even
Redmond who was initially frightened
seems calm right before his death when
the deed is done the surviving Invaders
become disoriented per served and sick
with Leonard even vomiting in the sink
this seems to indicate that once they
say humanity is judged they aren't in
control so who or what is the presence
of some higher power or polar of the
puppet strings are seemingly confirmed
later in the film as Eric states he saw
a glowing figure right before Redmond
was executed
[Music]